the latest effort to make the pga tour
look more like america this week's
tournament includes kamiyah johnson and
ryan alford two black golfers who were
invited by
the advocates pro golf association it's
a nonprofit organization developed in
2010 to prepare minority golfers to
compete at the highest level lilly
luciano met with the two men out on the
course
the two young golfers got a taste of
just how challenging the pga tour is
wednesday by the end of today ryan
alfred and kamiyah johnson will know if
they've done enough to make the cut here
at torrey pines and continue on through
friday and saturday it's alfred's first
time to play a tour event
how do you describe it what does it feel
like so unreal to be honest but as a kid
i mean i always dream to play on pga
tour so i mean it's definitely a dream
come true for me and i'm thankful and
very excited to see it up it's also
unreal for kamiyah johnson when he was
13 feeling helpless and overlooked in
school he dropped out of the eighth
grade jan auger who ran a tallahassee
golf course saw something in him as he
swung a stick back and forth by her
course she gave him a chance to play on
the course for a dollar a day pitting
himself and his mismatched set of clubs
against older members for the next five
years
johnson grew up without a dad and he
says that auger provided parental
guidance they still talk daily and
johnson calls her his second mom tell me
what it feels like to see him get to
this level considering where he started
from you know when he was just a little
kid and he was kind of lost
and um you know he loved golf he loved
the sport he's done it
largely by himself of course it takes a
village but he's done so great and i
just can't be happier for him
and as happiness comes full circle
johnson now draws his motivation from
his own newborn daughter it motivates me
right you know i don't like i don't want
my kid to grow up you know how i grew up
one of my main goals is just to continue
to grow as a person on and off the golf
course if i can do that just continue to
just be happy outside of golf and the
thing about it is my daughter
she makes me happy ryan alford credits
his dad who took him along to their
local course and then found just a few
years later his son was beating his
scores i take my hat off to my dad he's
definitely taught me everything
everything i know to this day i mean he
made me the man that i am to this day
but he's definitely giving me some vice
words of encouragement what do you hope
he does for other people i hope they see
this and uh see that you know you can
they could do it and all they have to do
is just stick to the
dreams and just
don't give up on it
the apga is a bold initiative to
diversify golf
founder ken bentley says significant
minority representation is long overdue
currently there are only four black pros
on the tour we want to not only get guys
on the pga tour but we want to make the
golf industry look like america
the apga tour is designed to inspire
much like another black golfer did for
some black athletes back in the 1990s
did tiger woods career make a difference
oh my god yes watching tiger i'm
competing in
out here for example watching him back
nine
sunday red on that just gives you chills
thinking about it over 20 years later
however and the tiger bounds which many
expected to improve representation in
the sport kind of fell flat the pga tour
has said that diversity remains the
sport's biggest challenge
but for both alfred and johnson today is
all about making the cut and a chance to
keep mixing it up with the world's best
for cbs mornings i'm lilia luciano at
torrey pines california
go kamaya and ryan see you have to see
it yeah you have to see it you have to
be around dude what what we noticed in
that piece is at a very young age they
had clubs in their hands it's just like
anything else you give a kid a book he's
going to read give a girl uh basketball
she's going to shoot and give her an
instrument she's going to play the same
thing with golf they have to start young
got to start young yeah you're not going
to get up at 15. exactly exposure
matters a lot in the meantime we are
cheering for ryan and kamiyah that's
right cheering for you guys today